well sharks beachgoers worst nightmare
of course so far in North Carolina there
have been eight shark attacks in just
under a month but at the Discovery
Network sharks are the stars of shark
week this week we spoke to andy
casagrande cinematographer of shark week
about the perils of shooting these
sharp-toothed creatures for me like the
two coolest things about my job are the
Sharks and the cameras and all the
technology involved so you know
especially with you know little cameras
like GoPros you can put them essentially
anywhere so that's really like
revolutionized how we can capture
different shots we put a GoPro on the
fin of a great white shark at the
Neptune Islands and that shark actually
swim around and filmed this other shark
Joan it was there's a pretty sketchy
moment where I'm trying to put the GoPro
on the fin and I kind of fall in the
water and you know cut to commercial it
was you'll have to watch to see what I
mean the reality is the Predators still
hunt the same way they always have for
millions of years the only thing that's
changing is the technology that we can
use to capture you know new insights
into their behavior and the fact that
essentially anyone now can go out and
grab their camera a GoPro or whatever
they want and go out and film their own
shark week to be I kind of feel like a
cinema scientist so everything from like
infrared cameras thermal cameras as i
mentioned drones to me are amazing i
captured some really nice great white
sharks breaching on my drone super high
resolution cameras like the red epic
shoots 6k resolution i also have a
phantom flex which shoots a thousand
frames per second at 4k so you can slow
down you know the bite of a shark or the
jump or the breach to like you know 52
you know a hundred times slower than the
speed of life it's not only mind-blowing
to watch it's actually helping
scientists learn more about the
predators and it's exciting it's fun I
think it's a great union between science
and cinema and shark week lets me do all
of that